all right so our dough has now doubled
she's big she's big
I know [ __ ] hey Allie hi I have heard
that you have a lot of experience and
expertise making people's favorite fast
foods at home I came to ask you if you
could make a treat that I love Krispy
Kremes when I was in middle school there
was like an explosion of Krispy Kreme
yeah and like I remember them right at
Krispy Kreme boom
you know doughnuts are donuts and I have
made them before
there's something about a Krispy Kreme
though they're just like perfectly
crispy and creamy almost untouchable but
we're gonna try let's touch him we're
gonna try I don't know if we can do it
but I believe that we can Krispy Kreme
is a yeasted dough so we're gonna start
with he's we would have thought that's
water well yeah so this is water we're
gonna start with some warm water and
we're gonna sprinkle our instant yeast
over the top is that is that the kind of
yeast that you get in packets at the
grocery store yeah it is exactly
so yeast is alive much like us yeah
hopefully already a thing to change it's
turning into like a teenager we need to
get her to a woman all right but now
that our yeast has phoned up we're gonna
sleep I mean she bloomed yeah she
bloomed into a woman we're gonna start
adding the rest of our ingredients for
the dough so we have one and a half cups
of warm milk you want to you can play I
wanna pour I'm always putting the people
who come to work you know I like it it
makes me feel accomplished we have a
half a cup of sugar 1/2 cup of sugar
just dump just dump her in and this is a
teaspoon of salt 2 eggs 2 eggs 2 eggs
and then a third of a cup of very soft
butter now we're gonna do 2 cups of
flour right in there and we're gonna
start to mix this
donut batter what so what's the mixing
technique so you can just kind of go for
it we want to break down the eggs and
the butter into the dough we're gonna
mix this dough and it'll be more like a
batter at first and then we're gonna
slowly start incorporating the rest of
the five cups of flour and it'll turn
more into a dough we ought to be gentle
with her but you know she's tough so if
you want to start mixing this together
so what we're looking for is to make it
more of like a shaggy or dough it'll be
just like a little bit easier to handle
so once we get there we can flip it onto
the table and start to knead it
okay it's like safe to touch safe to
touch yeah all right so this is kind of
like our shaggy dough it's come together
it's still a little bit loose but that's
okay so now it's gonna be times we need
this so it's still like pretty loose but
we're just gonna incorporate some more
flour as we go kneading is such an
important step because it's gonna help
you cut that like light and fluffy Airy
donut which is so classic to a Krispy
Kreme yeah you'll literally start to
feel the dough change it'll start to get
a little more like elastic and feel a
little like tighter as a dough toughen
her up you can also check if the dough
is ready by pressing your finger into it
so we want it to be elastic enough to
bounce back I think we still have a
little bit more to go so it's getting
there it's like pretty elastic but we
have a little bit more to go I think all
right so I think we're pretty good look
she looks so nice and I'm just gonna
kind of get into a nice little ball
she's a beauty she's a beauty so now I
have this greased glass bowl so I just
grease it with some oil I'm gonna pop
our dough right in there
you want it to be greased because it'll
allow your dough to rise up the sides of
the bowl instead of like stick we're
gonna cover this up with some plastic
wrap
you can also yeah we're gonna put her to
sleep at night she gets a little blanket
and she gets to go in a warm place to
about double in size we'll see you in
about two hours
all right so our dough has now doubled
she's big she's big
I know [ __ ] I'm into it alright so
basically what happened was our yeast
fed off of the sugar in the dough and
allowed it to rise and double so we know
it's all alive so now for the fun part
umm listen this is all been fun this has
all been pretty fun so we're just gonna
start to punch this down a little bit
you can do that oh yeah so that's a
hundred out we're just gonna take our
dough and we're gonna start to roll her
out so I'm gonna add a little more flour
and even on our rolling pin you don't
want anything to stick it's pretty like
elastic it's like a good firmness if you
want to start doing it with a rolling
pin try to keep it pretty even we're
gonna roll this out to be like on the
inner side I'm just on because the
donuts will puff up again as you work
the dough is gonna get a little bit
tougher to work with so we want to get
as many donuts as we can for the even
more fun part it just keeps getting more
fun I know I love it we are going to
start cutting out the donuts I'm just
using this ring cookie cutter and this
is smaller green cookie cutter I'm just
gonna dip this in flour just so it
doesn't stick to our dough both of them
and I can do so one
so we got one
okay so you can always like start to
kind of put this dough back together and
reroll it out and make more we're gonna
focus on these ones right now I'm gonna
kind of space these out so they're not
overlapping I'm going to cover these up
and let them hang out for like ten
minutes again another great stopping
point another great set a lot of power
to work
eating out the dough cutting him out oh
you can have a glass of wine or maybe
coffee all right so while our doughnuts
are hanging out we're gonna start on the
glaze what is your favorite type of
donut Krispy Kreme you cannot be a
classic classic for a reason yeah we're
gonna make just the basic clays which is
super easy just take some powdered sugar
and we're gonna mix that with some milk
1/4 of a cup of milk and I thought this
is like whiskey at first when I saw this
I've never seen a bottle of vanilla
extract that bacon the worst
we're just gonna live in this up with a
little bit of vanilla if you want to
stir that up and it should turn into a
glaze all right so that's our glaze and
we're about ready to fry our oil is on I
am going to get ready for once we start
to fry so I'm gonna pour our glaze onto
this baking sheet right on there a
waterfall of glaze can pull this off
okay so we want aren't whale to be at
about 375 if your oil is too hot the
outside will burn before the inside has
a chance to cook and if it's too low
it'll just be like an oily mess
so I'm gonna just carefully pick up one
I don't want to crowd the pot of oil so
we're just gonna do a few at a time so
just to be safe gonna drop it in with
our little spider here they're already
kind of puffing up and I'm just gonna
use like chopsticks is that that's
actually what they do at donut stores
once we have a good golden-brown color
on one side
I'm just gonna give it a little flip fry
it on the other side and then they'll be
done let's flip her over
see keep stabbing that one looks wise
looking pretty good good keep it going
until we get that nice golden brown
color on the other side and then we'll
pop them onto our baking tray with a
rack almost there on this three it is
still a process like to fry three at a
time
yeah it is taking a little bit longer
than I thought it was time to glaze em
well you should use a similar we want to
place them while they're still hot so
I'm gonna just go for it yes babe my
beauties babe oh yeah
little trickier than I anticipated you
know what I need a spatula we'll still
get them all on there they still look
pretty blaze will run off since it's a
loose glaze but that's why I wanted to
just kind of cover the whole doughnut
and like envelop it they look great see
the excess place kind of runs off and
you can continue to like use that yeah
exactly
we got our donut I think we did pretty
good I mean at least like the size and
shape is pretty comparable yeah our
glaze does not look quite as big doesn't
yeah this is like thick with the K this
is thick with tc's
yeah as always we're basing this off of
three different criteria so one is time
and effort how much time do we actually
put into making the donuts which was
kind of a considerable amount of time
it's a considerable amount of time but
it's not all spent working there were
two hours where we were just chilling
yeah - is cost now this might be one of
the scenarios where actually is cheaper
because so many people have these
ingredients in their pantries and their
fridges already three of course is
can we match or beat the taste of a
Krispy Kreme there's only one way to
find out all right so we have to try the
Krispy Kreme first obviously for the
baseline so take your pick
Goti Cheers
donut Cheers mmm it's great the glaze is
kind of what makes it a little crispier
as a donut but then it's still that like
melt-in-your-mouth creamy inside I'm
excited for these one I'm really a nice
warm fresh donuts it's so nice of this
look how perfect that one's like very
round this is nicely shaped this is a
good doughnut let's cheers Cheers
very good I feel like the Krispy Kreme
might be a touch fluffier but it's like
pretty close yeah this one hits you over
the head with sugar it's what is like
little sophisticated yeah this is how
booty people you don't know so you're
never gonna beat the convenience I'm
actually just going and getting a box of
doughnuts at Krispy Kreme but I think we
did a great job Alex I have to say thank
you very much for teaching me how to do
this just donut ask me to do this again
definitely
[Music]